propose d'aller du côté de la saône et
loire est précisément à chalon sur saône
où nous attend gilles platret le maire
sortant les républicains de chalon sur
saône gilles platret bonsoir est-ce que
vous ce soir nous redonner d'abord des
indications sur votre score ce soir
écoutez j'ai avec la leçon de la liste
en avant châlons à peu près obtenu 53%
des voix au premier tour
vous êtes ce soir donc réélu maire de
chalon va pas encore exactement mère
dans un contexte très particulier est ce
qu'il fallait faire ce premier tour de
scrutin
côté la question pouvait se poser elle a
été tranchée au sommet de l'état je
pense que il était légitime de se poser
la question notamment après les annonces
du premier ministre hier soir il était
dans les prérogatives du gouvernement du
président de la république de prendre
une décision ou une autre ils ont décidé
de maintenir les élections elles ont eu
lieu en tout cas pour leur premier tour
la question se posera bien davantage
pour le deuxième tour c'est une évidence
et et dès demain pour vous la réalité ce
sera plus les municipales ce sera
l'organisation de la ligne de défense
vous savez il ya eu quelque chose à ces
enfin incroyable on était dans une fin
de campagne mais en réalité on était
dans la lutte contre le virus
voilà des jours et des jours que nous
multiplions les réunions de crise
puisque l'idée c'est évidemment que la
commune de chalon sur saône seconde des
efforts de l'état pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus
nous étions ce matin alors que les
opérations électorales commencé en
réunion de crise avec le président du
grand chalon avec l'ensemble des
services pour savoir quels services nous
allions fermer
quels services nous allions maintenir
pour assurer la continuité qui étaient
dits essentiels en temps de crise dans
notre pays dans notre ville nous
recommençons demain matin enfin vous
savez on a effectivement été élu parce
qu'on a présenté un programme comme il
est bien légitime mais notre programme
aujourd'hui c'est la lutte contre le
coronavirus c'est la priorité c'est la
mobilisation de tous les services autour
de cette cause donc effectivement ça ne
cessera pas tant qu'on n'aura pas à
éradiquer cette propagation qui nous
menace et qui menacent de population
donc c'est notre priorité aujourd'hui
bien évidemment merci pour cette
réaction ce soir en direct gilles
platret
donc maire sortant de chalon sur saône
réélu ce soir nous